[MUSIC PLAYING]
GAYATHRI RAJAN: Thank you
everyone for being here,
especially the women.
But this is not work.
This is fun, so.
This is only day one off
some very, very packed days
so I hope you're getting
strapped for the ride.
We have a great series
of talks lined up
throughout the course
of the next two days.
So I'm on the Geo
Team within Google
and we're really excited to
share our journey with you
as we went out to
explore the world.
And I'd also like to
make very clear to you
that we think this is the
time, this is the era,
for location intelligence.
And I'm going to take
you through this,
through the conversation,
through our conversation.
I hope you feel this is a
conversation over the next hour
to really explain our
journey as well as how
we think about the future.
As you know, Google's
mission is a bold one.
It's to organize the
world's information.
And as part of the mission, very
early on it became clear to us
that we really had to
understand the real world
and not just focus on
online experiences.
So as part of this obsession
about really trying
to understand the real world,
we built three user experiences
to help our users get this
access to this great knowledge
that we were building.
These three experiences, I
think you are all familiar with.
The first one is
Maps, our Google Maps,
which is probably
how many of you found
your way to the Moscone today.
Local search, Google is a
search company and local search,
essentially, is when
you ask Google, not
just about what's
on the internet,
but what's around you.
And finally, Google
Earth where you
can see the planet, this
wonderful planet that we live
in without leaving your seat.
We've had some really big,
bold, world-scale successes
in these three applications.
On Google Maps at this point
we have about a billion users
using our products,
daily in many cases.
And we've taken the product
from a directions and navigation
product to a lot more.
Those of you who use
Google Maps today
will see notifications when
there is an anticipated traffic
delay for your daily
commute or you might even
choose to use Google
Maps to get a ride.
On the search side, what you
may not know is 6 out of 10
searches on Google are
actually local in nature.
So this is when users are asking
for say, if they type a query,
sushi.
They're not expecting a link
to a Wikipedia page about sushi
or even the definition of sushi.
They want to know where
to get great sushi.
Both these products, Google
Maps and our local search,
are powered by what we
term location intelligence.
Now I will explain to
you what that means
and I'm going to share
some examples of customers
and partners who use location
intelligence to really drive
their businesses and build
amazing consumer experiences.
And I hope, through the
course of this discussion
and after, you get some
really great ideas on how
you could use location
intelligence to power
your business and create the
kinds of user experiences
you've seen Google produce.
So let me take you a little bit
back, a trip down memory lane.
And I'm not talking
that long ago.
Just a decade ago, which doesn't
feel very long to me anymore.
When my family would
go out to explore,
go to a place that
was not familiar,
before we embarked on the trip
the first thing my husband did
was take another trip.
And this time it was to the AAA.
And he'd go to AAA and get
those little Tripticks,
and those paper maps, and
we'd stick it in the car,
and that's how we went out and
embarked on our explorations.
Around the same time, So we're
talking about a decade ago,
it was actually a
little bit longer,
11 years ago, Google set out to
do something really audacious
with Google Maps.
We decided we wanted to go and
digitize the map for the world.
So we'd have to leave paper
behind and actually create
a digital version of the
map, but we didn't just
do this for one location
or even a country.
Our goal was a lot
more ambitious.
We wanted to map
the entire world.
Every street, every surface,
every business, all of it.
And since then, as
you've seen, we've
not only brought maps
online all around the world,
we've also created these really
beautiful, rich experiences
where you can experience
the corners of the planet
from the tops of the highest
mountains to the oceans,
as I said, without
leaving your seat or even,
in this case,
learning how to dive.
And because increasingly we saw
that this world was becoming
mobile and connected, we brought
these experiences to mobile.
Essentially what we ended
up giving all the users
in the world with a phone was a
handy guide to the real world.
And this could help them then
get to where they were going,
provide the best experience
when they arrived,
and even provide
interesting ideas
for detours along the way.
Now, that sounds so great.
11 years later we're very
proud of where we've come,
but this was not easy.
We had several walls.
These were big hurdles that we
had to climb over the years.
Because what we were trying
to do was something that was
a one-of-a-kind.
It had never been done before
and certainly not at the scale
that we were aspiring for.
So when we hit some
serious technology hurdles,
what did we do?
We're a company of engineers.
And what do engineers do
when they find that there
is a technological hurdle?
They build new technology.
That's how they solve it.
They fix it.
So essentially what we did,
over the course of our journey
as we were scaling, was we
built new infrastructure
that would help us get to the
scale that we were aspiring to.
And we also found new ways
and rethought the ways
we would develop our products.
Google Cloud and
Machine Learning,
that these two very powerful
pairs, along with Google Maps,
changed our business.
And that's what we call, within
Google, location intelligence.
Now, location
intelligence gave us
within Google the scale, the
power, and the infrastructure
to help us with our dreams
of knowing everything
about the real world.
And now what we feel
really excited about
are the possibilities of
bringing this to your world.
What powered maps,
and local search,
and Earth can be used for
enterprise use cases as well.
But we, I want to go
further than that.
I mean, it's great, but we don't
think location intelligence is
just an imperative.
We actually think it's
a force multiplier
in this mobile connected world.
So what does that mean,
a force multiplier?
In this case, it means
that every service
that you're building
could be improved
with location intelligence.
You could elevate your
offering in a way that
could be disruptive,
disruptive to your business,
disruptive to the ecosystem.
And build solutions that
have location based insights
and can be delivered at
scale and in real time.
Now, I'll share with
you a few examples
of how enterprises have used
the rich data of Google Maps,
the scale of Cloud, and the
power of Machine Learning
to grow their businesses.
Because it's already
happening today.
So let me start with
Google Maps API.
This is one of our
older products.
We launched this
around the same time
as we launched our consumer
Google Maps product.
And over the years, as we
continue to trade and improve
our consumer
product, we continue
to augment our Maps API.
I think several of
you in this room
are probably familiar with this.
This Is almost a decade old
and constantly advancing.
So we see four main use cases in
how customers and partners use
our Maps API.
Display, Go,
Locate, and Explore.
So what's Display?
Display is simple.
It's when you want to put a
map on your app or website.
Go helps users navigate
around the world.
Locate is the use case for
tracking uses or assets
around the world.
And finally, Explore is
this really rich knowledge
of places and businesses
around the world
that Google has captured
that we make available to you
through our Places API.
So let's start with Display.
As I said, this is
at the core of Maps.
This is when we
use our visual map
and provide this to you so
you can build custom maps that
can be personalized
for your use cases
and for the needs of your users.
Now, here's a great
example of a customer who's
used Google Maps, the
visualization API,
to build a really
great experience.
So they created a tool called
GoodHome, which essentially,
because they're in the
insurance business,
they really needed to find a way
to give their users the ability
to get personalized
quotes so they could start
the process of converting
them from users on a website
to customers.
And so, with GoodHome
what they did was
they created a
personalized experience
that was personalized for your
locale, for where you were.
So incorporating risk.
So, for example, in a given
neighborhood, what the crime
rate was in that neighborhood.
Or in a region that is swampy,
what the risk of flooding is.
Or if you're around
here, the risk
of the big one hitting you.
So what they found, and
this was really impressive,
they found that
with this localized
personalized
experience users were
350% more likely
to ask for a quote
and then get to conversion.
And what is also
pretty awesome is
they were able to
go from concept,
from thinking about
this as a design phase,
to completing and launching
the site in under 90 days.
So this is really powerful
because, ultimately,
the technology that we
were providing really
came to a place where a
customer at the end of the day
was able to get a
better experience.
Let's take the other, the
next use case, navigation.
What we found is, over
the years customers
have used our advanced
navigation capabilities
to really transform businesses.
And as you're seeing, I
think in recent years,
disrupt whole industries.
A great example of this is Lyft.
They're a great customer and
they use our real time location
data to connect
drivers and riders.
If any of you have used
a Lyft, Lyft or an Uber,
I think you'll see that that
whole experience around, right
from when you find where
your driver is as he's coming
to you, through your
ride experience,
and as well as the driver as
he is making his way to get you
to your destination, all that
is powered through our Maps
navigation APIs.
And what really has happened
over the last very few years
actually, is this
technology has actually
created an entirely
new business category,
something that we didn't
exist a few years ago.
And they've had some phenomenal
successes, in the case of Lyft.
There were two
million Lyft riders
monthly with 100,000 drivers
on payroll in 200 cities.
So I came in a Lyft
today to the Moscone.
Previously, I'd come
to San Francisco
and I'd worry about parking
and all I do now is book a ride
and I'm here.
So what's really interesting
about this use case is,
if you think about
it, Google set out
to understand how
the world moved
and how users moved
around the world.
And essentially now, what
our customers have done
is they've used our
technology and our products
to change the way users move.
So I think that's really cool.
The third use case is
closely tied to navigation,
but this is really
around tracking
of vehicles, people, assets,
even connected devices
with IoT around the world.
Now, location tracking makes
supply chains very efficient
and logistics a lot
more competitive.
In this new world where it
is about on-demand real time
delivery, these are
now table stakes.
And here's a customer that's
built something that's
really cool using our APIs.
So DPD is a customer that uses
our live tracking, basically
our location APIs, to deliver
3.6 million parcels daily.
And as they move to our APIs
what they were able to do
was to introduce live
tracking of those parcels.
So, in this case, what you
can do with DPD is the sender
and the recipient can both
look at the exact position
of a package through
its transit following
the journey on a
map and the arrival
ETA is within 30 minutes of
the projected delivery time.
Now, a few years
ago, if you remember,
we'd know we'd get this
on a Thursday maybe
and sometimes a package would
come in on a Friday instead.
And here we are now, tracking
these things in real time,
expecting to track
them in real time.
And even, in my case because I
travel a lot, from time to time
I'll redirect the
packages when I know
that I'm not going to be home.
This transparency, this
control, this level of service
that was just not possible
before, are table stakes now.
Customers demand it.
And the technology
that we've provided
that our customers are now using
essentially make this possible.
And finally, the last
use cases around Explore.
Now everyone uses Google,
Google's local search.
And what we really thought
was really important to do
was to provide.
Because we know that
ultimately there
are users who come to your
products and your services
that don't come to Google's
local search, not always.
That we wanted to
make sure that you
had access to the same
rich knowledge of places
around the world
through our Maps APIs.
So here's an example of a
customer that's done exactly
that.
The travel aggregator site
called Tripping, what they do
is they use our
Maps API for Places
to get address listings
and destination information
for their rental properties.
So what they do is they take
the location information
from each listing that they
have and they drop it on a map.
And because of the way
we've made this work
it automatically scales the
map to match your query.
So, for example, if you're
searching for rentals in Paris
it'll map it to the
correct zoom level.
And if you decide you want to
get a little bit more local
and you want to look at
neighborhoods around the Eiffel
Tower.
I don't know why you would
because it's really crowded
around there, but if you did
you'd get to that tighter zoom
almost immediately without
users having to pinch, and pan,
and zoom.
So it's all
beautifully integrated
in the consumer experience.
The other thing that Tripping in
particular found really useful
was just having
accurate address data.
So what they found was that
the rental property owners
didn't always provide
the full address,
making it really hard
for potential renters
to get to the place.
But that was not
a problem anymore
because with Google's
Maps API we essentially,
and because of our knowledge of
the addresses around the world,
we could complete it
for you, essentially.
So if we see an
address that's not
complete we can match it with
the address in our records,
essentially fill in the blanks.
So what's really awesome about
this case was the numbers.
When I first saw
the slide I thought
it was 200% increase, which
seemed really awesome,
but this was closer to 2400%.
And they got two million
users very quickly after they
launched this new site.
Now this is not a big company.
You probably have not all
heard of Tripping the way
you may have heard of Lyft.
But as a result
of this they were
able to recently
close a series B round
and get more venture funding.
And I say this
because it's examples
like this that get us
really excited within Google
because they're exciting
to see the birth
of these new companies that
are able to use technology
to drive these really
great user experiences
and create new businesses.
For our customers
that use our tools
and provide great experiences,
now this is really exciting.
We think in every
one of these cases
they've done something
very special.
But there's another class
of emerging use cases
that operate at massive scale.
And these are new.
These are happening but
there are still emerging,
and they are made possible
by the computation
scale of Google Cloud Platform.
You're here for a reason
because of Google Cloud.
And I want to tell you that
when you think about Maps,
Google Cloud is a great pair.
And here are a few examples
of why we think that is so.
So prime example here of this
really magical powerhouse
pairing of Google
Cloud and Google Maps
is a product called
Earth Engine.
This was developed at Google.
And what we did here was
we turned Google Cloud's
enormous computing horsepower on
this rich world of geo datasets
that we have.
And what we were able to
do was to enable insights
at unprecedented speeds.
Now, the first application
of Earth Engine
was not commercial.
It was actually about mapping
the forests of the Earth.
It's just, it's a beautiful
thing because ultimately,
if this is about
the Earth, our trees
are an incredible
natural resource.
And having knowledge,
and access,
and understanding how our
forest ecosystem is doing
is actually a really important
part of our mission as well.
But there had never
been, previously,
a way to systematically
map changes in the Earth,
map it to forest areas
at a high resolution.
And that's what we did.
We partnered with Google Forest
Watch and Professor Hansen
and created the world's
first high resolution
global forests change map.
So those of you, I hope
you were able to see
that this map got successful
successively pinker as I
was speaking.
That was basically what
you could see happen in
that very few seconds was really
a recording of the changes
in deforestation within the US.
So the more pink you see
the worse the news is.
And what we're also
able to do is not only
track the status of
these forest losses,
we can also provide
alerts on when
there are recent forest losses
so we can keep this updated.
Now, to create
this global forest
map we had to process,
this was not trivial,
we had a process 650,000
images across 10,000
Cloud-based servers in parallel.
Now, this would take a
single computer 15 years.
That's even well before the
time we created Google Maps.
And we were able to
do this with Earth
Engine in just a few days.
Now, if we could only figure out
how to regrow those trees that
fast, but these are
some of the examples
you can see of just the
power with Cloud, and Maps,
and the applications
that can be provided.
Something we tried at Google,
but we also have another
example here. .
And this one's very
different So I'm
taking you from the forest
to the world of Poke stops.
So here we have
Niantic and Pokemon Go.
Who here hasn't
played Pokemon Go?
Wow.
OK.
I should help you download
the app as you leave.
I'm not a gamer, but
I spent, I would say,
at least a week last
summer playing the game
and really discovering
my neighborhood.
I had not walked
many of these streets
so it was a very unusual, a
very innovative experience.
A completely new
gaming experience
that starts to give you
glimpses of the world we
see in the future of
augmented reality experiences.
And what they did was
they basically leveraged
a custom version of our Maps
API, among other sources,
to create this gaming
experience, which is great.
We loved it.
But there was another really
interesting angle here.
In addition to creating
this really unique gaming
experience, they
found themselves,
as could be evidenced in
just the number of hands
in this room,
there were only two
so you can imagine if
we extrapolate this
around the world, they
found themselves caught up
in this unexpected
explosive growth.
Now, growth is always a
good thing for a company.
2x 3x, you think you can handle.
They.
Went up to 50x in
that first week.
That's meltdown time.
But in this case, both
Niantic and the engineers
from Google Cloud were able
to work together and help
them scale.
And this is just the beginning.
As I said, this is
the first glimpse
of what we believe
is really going
to be some of the
experiences we see more
of in the future,
where companies
start to create these
augmented reality experiences.
Where they merge the
world with other artifacts
and create these really
incredible augmented reality
experiences.
I hope these two
examples gave you
a sense, a glimpse, of just, the
power and the capabilities when
you pair rich real world
data from Maps with the.
Computing power
and scale of GCP.
So going back again a
little bit to our journey,
because we found that
every time we go,
we rewind and look at where
we are, we found, as I said,
we kept finding ourselves
hitting roadblocks.
So in the early days
in order to create
the digital map
for Google Maps we
had a team of engineers,
not thousands.
Google always runs really lean.
We had a sizable
team of programmers
that were building these
applications with hand coded
rules.
And this was fine.
This was great.
It was working.
Until it wasn't.
As we started to build
richer experiences
and we raised the bar on
what it meant to be a map,
it was not just a digital
version of a paper map.
It was a map that had
to live and breathe.
It had to be in real time.
We wanted rich experiences
that could even
give you some prediction
about the future.
We found ourselves in a position
where our old development
strategies just wouldn't scale.
We couldn't have gone
from 100 to 1,000.
We would have had to
have tens of thousands
of engineers to do
that, to basically meet
the demands of our dreams.
So that's when we turned
to Machine Learning.
With Machine Learning
we essentially
gave computers the ability
to learn from the data
and make predictions
on the data.
So a great example of Machine
Learning on Google Maps
is a feature we launched very
recently called Popular Times.
So here we're able to give you
an indication for any place
that you want to visit, what
might be the popular times
of the less busy times.
So you can decide how you
want to schedule your visit.
And we did this with
Machine Learning.
Another great example is the
map you see on the right.
So here the reds indicate
high traffic and the greens
are roads that don't
have much traffic.
Now, our Machine Learning models
predicted these traffic delays
in Wyoming based on
weather changes ahead of us
even getting the data feeds.
So we knew what was
going to happen.
Not we, our Machine
Learning models knew.
And this notion of having
predictive real time
experiences just
simply would not
have been possible if we hadn't
invested in Machine Learning.
So with Machine Learning,
and I think there are many,
many talks here over
the next coming days.
I would really ask you to
go spend some time there
because this is fundamentally
going to change the way we
think about almost everything.
But back to our case.
What we've found is
we can use the signals
from connected devices, from
real time maps, and location
data, and answer new
questions and make
really powerful predictions
about the real world.
But what is equally exciting
is that this deep knowledge
that we have now, this
understanding of location,
and Machine Learning, and
Cloud computing, we now
have the potential to
help you, enterprises,
build the smart
assistive solutions
that we've been trying to
release on our own Google
surfaces.
So here's a great example.
It's a really powerful example.
It's also a deeply
humbling example.
So I'm going to take you from
the forests now to the oceans.
The health of our planet's
oceans, I think you all know,
are under threat from
global overfishing.
And what's great though, is
some of these smart assistive
solutions that I was
talking about are now
being used to monitor, prevent,
and address these situations.
So here's how this is happening
in this particular case.
There are about 200,000
vessels around the world,
shipping vessels, that broadcast
their location, their course,
their speed back to satellites
up in the skies, fleets
of satellites that record
these streams and then transmit
the information back to Earth.
Now, we took this
information in partnership
with the Global Fishing
Watch organization
and using Google's Cloud
computing and our Machine
Learning models, we were able
to pinpoint which of the vessels
there were fishing vessels, when
and where they were fishing,
and also be able to make an
assessment of whether there
was overfishing happening
in regions of the planet.
Now this is the
first of its kind.
This has never previously
been done before.
This computation of this scale,
with billions of data points,
and making these sorts of
inferences on where we believe
overfishing is
happening could not
have happened without
the power of Maps, Cloud,
and Machine Learning.
So taking this back,
I'd said at the start,
we think location
intelligence, this combination
of Maps, Cloud, and Machine
Learning is a force multiplier.
In this case we
really think it's been
proven to be a force for good.
So in case you've forgotten,
this is the magic combination.
Allstate, Lyft, DPD, Tripping,
Earth Engine, Global Fishing
Watch, Pokemon Go,
I think that's it.
None of these solutions
would have been possible
when we began our
journey 11 years ago.
I'd love to say we actually
had this great plan
and we saw all this
coming, we didn't
because all these experiences
and all these great examples
that you've heard of were
made by businesses like yours.
Our customers have
made incredible strides
even as we've been
making our journey
with Google Maps, and
Search, and Earth Engine,
and in many, many cases
well beyond our imaginings.
So they really pushed
the envelope upon us
and that's actually
what gets us excited
because then that's a problem
that our engineers are
excited to solve.
What we found now
is the problems
are becoming exponentially
more challenging.
A few years ago customers
would come to us and say,
I'd love to get a
map on my website.
Help me visualize the world.
Help me provide
custom data on a map.
And these are all
really good use cases,
but now the problems become
a lot more sophisticated.
Now it's around, help me plan,
provide me insights, tell me
what's moving, who's
moving, give me
predictions on where
they're going to go next,
or what's going to
happen in the world next.
From visualization to
making these major business
decisions, at the center of it
all is location intelligence.
This is, I said
at the beginning,
and we truly
believe because this
is what we're hearing
from our customers
and this is what
we're starting to see,
there is this
incredible momentum
now for location intelligence.
I'll leave you with
this final point
and actually, I think I left
the most important point
till the end.
When I started out saying,
and actually the topic here is
location intelligence
is a force multiplier,
a force multiplier need
something to act on.
Right?
I mean, otherwise it's going
to multiply in a vacuum.
And that's something
really is you.
It's your ideas.
It's your initiative.
You have the tools
and the talent.
And the most important
of all, and this
is something we have
realized over and over again,
you know the customer.
You know the customer
better than we do.
And when you put
that together, that's
when something really
special happens.
Now I've given you
a few examples,
but I think it's always
more powerful when it comes
through some of our partners.
So I'm going to
now leave the stage
and pass it to two
of our partners.
SADA and Vagabond,
who can share with you
their experiences as they
went through this journey
towards building great
businesses and experiences
with location intelligence.
To start with I'm going
to welcome Patrick,
who's head of Cloud and
Geospatial Technology at SADA
Systems.
Thank you.
Welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK SKOGLUND: What I
want to talk to you all about
today is this idea of
Cloud and Maps, right?
How do you incorporate
Cloud And maps past an idea?
How do you bring it to a
company and actually impact
that company?
So before I talk about each one
of these bubbles, so to speak,
I want to talk a little
bit about the use case
of a company we work with, AAA.
I'm sure all of you
have heard of AAA
unless those that don't play
Pokemon Go also don't use AAA,
I don't know.
The point here is, AAA is a
longstanding company, right?
They've been in
business for a while.
They have a widely
adopted business model
that's made them successful.
So how do you take that
long-standing business
model and that ideology that's
made this company so successful
and convince them that
you can grow it, right?
How do you increase efficiency
of an already created business
model?
And so what we did, we being
SADA Systems and Google,
we sat down with AAA's core team
responsible for the customer
success of their
roadside assistance.
And so customer success
in this instance
pertains not just to you, as
the end user with a flat tire
or what have you, but also
their operating team, right?
So what are their operating
team members doing today
on their roadside
assistance platform?
And one of the things
that we really focused on
was understanding
and identifying
every single aspect
that they're using today
with AAA's roadside assistance.
So what that means is, not just
the system, but the actual end
users, right?
So those end users
that are being
impacted by the system itself.
And so we basically built
out interviews in what
we call a gap analysis model.
And that's really what curated
building this relationship
with AAA, right?
How do you bring
Cloud, and Google Maps,
and this idea of
those two things
to truly benefit and
impact a business?
No less a business that's
been, as I mentioned before,
longstanding, right?
How do you breach and get over
that obstacle, so to speak.
And so that really brings
me to these points, right?
So I talked about building
this relationship.
We'll get into how
we really carried out
the methodology
of problem solving
and then the overall
solution we provided.
So for the tech
heads in here, it's
going to get a little
technical as it
pertains to what
we've built, but I'll
keep it business conceptual.
The next piece is the
relationship with Google,
right?
So why is it that SADA was
able to build this model?
Why couldn't AAA just
do this themselves?
They have Google.
They can go Google
things themselves.
So what unique qualities
does SADA and Google
working together give
to a company like AAA?
And then the last piece and
the obvious is the benefits.
Great.
So really these four
core things in terms
of building this relationship.
And so if you look
at our business
model, Google's
business model, there's
two aspects of outreach, right?
There's this digital
sense of outreach
where you look up Google Maps,
you can identify and understand
Google Maps APIs, Google.
Cloud but then there's a
second form of outreach.
And that's more on
the sales rep side.
And we really want to get
consultative and expand
that knowledge base of
Google Maps and Cloud.
Trying to understand
and identify
how what you read online impacts
you as a business, right?
And really trying to take that
narrative to the next level
and core, in this
instance, to what
AAA does on a day-by-day basis.
And so that involves our team,
our sales team, our engineering
team, Google's sales team,
Google's engineering team,
to really sit and make these
things unique and specific
to AAA.
And that, in an obvious
sense, brings a great customer
response, right?
It's one thing if
I myself go online,
and I'm AAA in this instance,
I go online and look up
all these different
aspects of Maps API,
but what do I do with it, right?
And so that's where Google
and SADA come in and go
through exactly what I
just mentioned before,
that narrative itself.
And then you have this approach,
this overall unique aspect
of an approach.
And really what you'll
see in a few slides here
is what we built.
But it truly is
a unique experience with AAA.
We built a custom web service
using Google Maps APIs
and Google Cloud Platform
that essentially gives them
a data repository specific
and unique to AAA's Roadside
Assistance team.
So the solution that we
really built for AAA,
what's the breakdown
in the architecture
of the system itself?
So what we're looking at
here is AAA and the obvious.
And then these
different components
of Google Cloud Platform, Google
Maps APIs and Street View.
So how are these three things
used within AAA ecosystem?
And what we did was, we used the
data output of Google Maps API.
So that includes
geocoding, point
of interest data, so
Places API, as well as
the obvious, which is just
the core base map itself.
Now the reason this
is so important
is that, when we were going
through that interview process
that I mentioned previously
with those customers being
the operators, they
in fact were using
the public version of
Google Maps in addition
to their previous platform.
And what I mean by that is,
their previous platform,
for example, didn't
have Street View.
So they, in fact, would get a
customer call or somebody has
broken down car, for
example, and I say,
I'm on this intersection and
I'm right across from the Taco
Bell.
What their actual, the
AAA member would do is,
they would go outside
of their application,
pull up Street View on the
public version of Google Maps,
, and identify exactly where
that Taco Bell is, right?
So this is an
obvious inefficiency
where we're taking
the power of Google
from an enterprise
perspective, right?
This is an instance
where you're using
Street View to identify where an
actual customer's location is.
And I'll talk about the benefits
of that in just a moment.
But really, this
is the core concept
of leveraging the
different aspects of Google
and how we've built a
custom workflow for AAA.
So we essentially,
with Google, built
a complete custom
web service that
takes into account routing.
So they actually use our
tool for vehicle rerouting.
So we'll take into
account vehicle type
and then suggest the
appropriate route.
And then that gets pushed
into their actual system.
And so we use Cloud SQL to
match the schema associated
with their current database.
And in the end, what
you're really driving at
is an end user experience.
So not only do we give
them a restful web service,
but we actually gave them
a unique user experience.
And so, really what
you're looking at here
is my ability as a AAA
Roadside Assistance member
to use Google Maps, the
tool that I'm already
familiar with on a day-to-day
basis in my personal lifestyle,
on an enterprise side.
In addition to that, I'm using
the power of Google Cloud
Platform to generate
this massive web
service created by SADA
and partnering with Google.
So this concept of
working with Google,
so we're talking
about product insight,
advanced access, Google's
design development,
so what does all
this mean, right?
And so our company,
SADA, has really
gone through a cultural shift.
We're focused on hiring
the core developers.
So we, in the past we were
seeing as a consultant, right?
We're now going towards that
shift of being an engineering
company first.
10 engineers for every
single sales rep, right?
That's our goal.
And the reason
behind that is we're
really taking a lot of
the adopted methodologies
of Google.
Building a core product
that can represent itself
or building a core
competency in services
that can represent itself
above and beyond what any sales
rep can come in and
talk about, that's
core to what we're
trying to do here.
And that's really
what has driven us
to the Partner of the Year.
So over the past few years
we've been recognized
globally, although not this
year, by Google for this work,
right?
So that's just one instance.
AAA is just one use
case where we're
driving at that type
of relationship,
at how it can impact
businesses such as AAA.
So the last piece
I'll talk about
is the actual
benefits here, right?
So you have user
adoption and utilization.
And so, utilization is
core to someone like me.
If you look at other
products, anything,
could be Microsoft Word, right?
Do people use 100%
of Microsoft Word?
And so that's another
focus that we had.
Not only giving them Google
Maps, but focusing on,
do they use 100% or close to
100% of the application, right?
And that's one of the things
that we have come to find
is significant growth versus
their previous system.
So in their previous system
you had certain users using 10%
as superusers, other people
not even using it, using
the public version
of Google Maps
to get to a specified location.
Then we get into increased
efficiency on calls, right?
So having more accurate
data, the ability
to go to Street View, all
of these different aspects
of a revised tool.
And the obvious relays itself
to increased efficiency.
Then we talk about
increased accuracy.
So Google, as it pertains to
updating its geocoding, right?
If you really look
at what is core
to Google Maps, its people.
And people are really
what's built it out, right?
It's a massive system, massive
ecosystem, extremely complex
from an infrastructure
level, but people
are responsible
for the accuracy,
in terms of updating locations.
I just moved into a home,
it's not showing up on Google.
Or I just opened up a new store,
All of this is core to
building out that accuracy
and being taken advantage of
again at an enterprise level.
And then the last piece
is a pretty obvious one,
which is CSat, or customer
satisfaction, across the board.
So not only are we
increasing efficiency
as it pertains to an
individual truck driver getting
to you all faster when
you get a flat tire,
but we're also
increasing the efficiency
of the actual operator, right?
And so across the board
we've completed true customer
satisfaction.
So in conclusion, just to kind
of bring this full circle,
we're talking about how
Google Maps and Google Cloud
Platform directly integrated
with a system that
was built to match the unique
aspects of a long standing
business, has helped them change
the way that they internally
map out which route to take in
accordance to which customer,
and really building out
an end user experience
for their version of an end user
above and beyond the actual,
you all the customer,
but their operating team.
And so, that's really what the
power of Google Cloud Platform
and Google Maps gave to AAA.
So with that all said, I'm now
going to be introducing Michael
from Vagabond Vending to talk
a little bit about everything
that they're using
Google Maps API for.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL LOVETT:
Thank you, Patrick.
Thanks, guys.
Who wants to talk
about vending machines?
A concept that's near and dear
to everybody's heart, right?
So thanks for spending
the next 10 or so minutes
just exploring
this topic with me.
Let's see a show of hands.
How many in the room
have visited a vending
machine in the last year or so?
Don't be shy.
I know most of you have.
Almost all of you.
OK, that's good.
So please keep your hands
up if that experience has
in some way or another
been, let's say subpar.
Many, many of you, OK.
So that's the problem
we're solving.
So thanks very much, Patrick.
And thank you three for
inviting me to share
the stage with you today.
Thanks also to Google and to
our integration partner Wolpert
for an excellent partnership
and a powerful partnership
over the past couple of years.
My name is Michael.
I'm in from DC,
Washington DC, where
I live with my lovely
wife in an apartment
with a door that
constantly revolves
with friends and family.
That's how we like to keep it.
That's our top priority
in life, my wife and I,
is to have the
time and the money
to do what we want to do
with our friends and family.
Five years ago I founded
a technology company
based on the
premise of returning
the same to small business
owners in America.
The core premise, or the core
mission, of Vagabond's team
is to improve the
quality of life
of our customers, small
business owners, in this case,
in the vending industry.
The small ones want
time back in their life.
The big ones want
better processes
so we can drive more
profits to the bottom line.
And all the
stakeholders in-between,
whether they're counting
coins, or they're
working in the warehouse,
or they're out on the roads,
want some sort of purpose and
fulfillment in their jobs.
And they also want a way to
participate in the bottom line
and that's what the Vagabond
team comes into work every day
to deliver to the stakeholders
in vending businesses.
Luckily for all of
us involved there's
an enormous financial incentive.
It's a $20 billion
market in the US alone.
Can you believe it?
$20 billion dollar bills
flow through six million
vending machines
operated by 8,000 family
businesses in America alone.
So this is, another
way to look at it
this is nearly $20 billion
individual retail buying
decisions.
So later on in the
presentation I'm
going to tell you a little
bit about some new products
that Vagabond is releasing
that rely heavily
on Google's infrastructure that
help us link the people who
are buying things with the
people who are selling things
and the people who make things.
But before I do,
I want to tell you
a little bit of
back story about how
Google, and Wolpert, and
Vagabond got together to turn
the industry on its head.
So our customers own and operate
between one and a few thousand
of these vending machines
between North and Central
America.
For the last five years
we've been operating
in IoT or machine-to-machine
communications network,
bringing live sales
and machine data back
from the field that
sources mobile and web
products that our customers
use and their teams
use throughout the day
to make better decisions.
Imagine if you owned
1,000 vending machines
between here, downtown
San Francisco, to San Jose
and maybe Oakland.
Right?
Before Vagabond you've
got a lot of problems.
On these roads it's
a nightmare, must be.
So our operators are
using Vagabond in order
to figure out where to go,
exactly what products to bring
in order to bring those machines
back to capacity, what products
are selling best, exactly how
to get there of course, who's
stealing from them, and
otherwise financially
administrate their business.
So operators, in doing so, can
expect for their net profit
margins to triple, to quadruple
because their revenues are
higher because they're
stocking the right products.
Their costs are lower because
we're simply accomplishing more
with less guys driving
less trucks fewer miles
and their theft is eliminated.
In a $20 billion industry
in the US 80% of that
is still conducted in cash,
if you can believe that.
And 15% of that cash gets
stolen before it gets back
to the warehouse.
So that's a $2 billion
dollar problem.
So before Vagabond
you've got problems.
And they're pretty easy to see.
So I want to tell
you a little bit
about how Google and Wolpert
helped us solve them.
So you've got 1,000 machines and
we need to know where they are.
You guys would be amazed to
know how many customers present
themselves to us without
knowing exactly how many
vending machines they have.
These are $5,000 assets.
They don't know how many they
have, much less where they are.
So we've got to know where
they are so Wolpert helped
us put together
some facilities that
allows the operators to
geolocate the machines
and actually drag and
drop precise locations
through Google's geocoding APIs.
OK so now we can drop a machine
in the cafeteria in front
of a building and another
one in a loading dock
in the back, which is serviced
by a different entrance.
So you can see how that can make
an impact when you're trying
to get to 50 machines in a day.
And we've got to make it
easy for them to onboard
and us to onboard the customer.
I won't bore you with the
dozens and dozens of data points
that we need for each
of your 1,000 machines
in order to onboard
into our ERP system,
but making it easy to
actually plot the machine,
establish an address, and
pinpoint an exact location
through geocoding
and Places APIs
is an incredible enhancement
to the onboarding process.
So once we have the
machines plotted on the map,
our ERP tools and
our IoT systems
are able to layer real
time information directly
onto the pinpoints on the map
so that users or operators,
route managers, can make each
truck's schedule for the day.
And they can filter
those end points
by the route, whose route is it,
the geography of the machines,
how much cash is
sitting there waiting
for them in the machine,
how full the machine is,
and whether or not the machine
needs other kind of service.
Now, this relies heavily on
Google's JavaScript's API.
And once the route is
set, our route operators
can use the Directions
API to make sure
that trucks' route is going
to be optimal for the day.
From there, the
warehouse can load
the truck with
exactly what products
they're going to need to
bring all those machines up
to capacity, and they're
off on their way.
So you can already sort of see
just by layering real time data
over top of Google's
mapping products
how much impact you can have
on a small to medium business
in America.
But you've still got problems.
So in order to provide this
service to vending operators
we need to be able to
connect the machines.
And really the only
right way to do
it is to connect all
the machines, right?
Historically we've been
able to do this primarily
through third party
credit card readers.
The problem with that is that
they're just way too expensive.
They're so expensive,
in fact, to run
on a remote automated retail
location that only about 20%
of the vending machines,
the 6 million vending
machines in the
country, are ever
going to generate enough
money, enough revenue,
to warrant the cost of
a credit card reader.
The hardware is too
expensive, the data fees
are too expensive,
the transaction fees
for micro-payments
are through the roof,
but consumers are starting
to more and more demand
flexible payment options.
I mean honestly, who
carries cash anymore?
So I want to introduce to
you for the first time, Viv,
a revolutionary new
payment service that
allows consumers to
buy from machines
and pay any way you like.
These are instant
mobile transactions
that don't require
you touch the machine.
These are real live e-commerce
transactions occurring 100%
in the Cloud, but delivering
you product in real life
right in front of your eyes.
Now, in addition to providing
us and our operators
a really inexpensive way to
connect the machines to our ERP
servers so that we
can provide them
all sorts of great
operational benefits,
Viv lets us create
relationships directly
between buyers and
sellers, between consumers
and operators.
And it also helps brands deliver
value directly to consumers.
And as you can imagine, we're
driving a lot of the smarts
through Google's engines.
So just open the app, scroll
through the menu of items,
select your product, view
nutritional information,
loyalty offerings,
promotional details,
choose your payment option,
and the product drops.
No touching the machine,
no NFC connection,
no point of sale
hardware, and no teller.
So I know what you're
thinking, right now,
most of you in the
audience are thinking,
well, it's about
freaking time, Michael,
that I can do this at a
vending machine, come on.
OK, but I can
assure you that this
is a technological feat of
magic in the world of vending
machines.
We're talking about
an industry, we're
talking about releasing this
technology to an industry who
counts the acceptance
of $1 bill as one
of their great innovations
in the last 40 years.
So how does it work?
So each time we
install a piece of IoT
gear it calls home using
Google's Geolocation APIs
and it gives us the
approximate location.
Now, remember that operators
are using our ERP systems
to apply an exact geocode of
where that machine actually is.
We're also, in this
case, constantly
able to geolocate Viv users that
are walking around the machines
or walking around the block.
We're using Bluetooth, or
BLE, to solve the last puzzle
piece of the equation between
the location of the machine
and the location of the user.
We're using it to improve
the location accuracy,
all these things
place together, we're
using it to determine the
orientation of machines
in a machine bank.
So oftentimes there's
three or four machines
in the same place.
And of course, we're using
Bluetooth to also deliver
the service to consumers.
From there we're driving
payments directly
through Android Pay,
all brought to you
through a combination of
Vagabond's ERP, Wolpert
engineering, Google Maps API,
and the Viv consumer platform.
So with powerful tools from
Google, Vagabond has been able,
and support from
Wolpert, excuse me,
Vagabond has been able to
revolutionize the consumer
buying experience with
the Viv consumer platform.
We have the technology today
to deliver massive profits back
to small businesses in America.
And now we can create direct
relationships between buyers,
sellers, and makers of goods, in
real time at the point of sale
directly at the purchase.
All of this put
together enables us
to expand the footprint of
Google's already very powerful
advertising platform directly
into the consumer experience
through the power of
location based services
and the Internet of Things.
Thank you very
much for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]